welcome back from the the turkey weekend
now while people are walking in I
thought since Mary Claire showed you
something from New Yorker I had
something to show you to that was had
caught my eye caught my eye here just
fairly nice okay his work well done you
got that I you know I'm not really
giving a lecture on punctuation today
but this one is one of the one of the
now that shows a different medium of the
you know the people still use
dictaphones does anyone has everyone
seen a dictaphone in the last five year
I don't know but gum now I call so yes
reporters use telephones oh absolutely
oh I see especially in the when they're
writing up these little BIOS okay good
now now then we had a trouble the other
day about getting a good example of a
dangling participle and so so I also
have one of those here please Eddie good
way down to the bottom no no yeah that's
it right here okay
I think this helps to understand it this
helps to understand the principles of by
dangling participles as well as any
example ever seen ok count now I have I
have good news and bad news but for
people today and actually i have several
of each kind so I'll alternate between
the two first of all one one piece of
good news is that that mary claire has
agreed to to to speak also on wednesday
because there was much too much to say
last wednesday and so we can get more
detailed between the lines of the latter
parts of her hand out that she gave us
on wednesday so another piece of good
news is the following Wednesday a week
from this Wednesday Paul how much will
be a guest speaker i have i have finally
got enough courage to ask him and he was
he was enthusiastic so he will be so i
think this will this will be a fitting
that a fitting way to you know have have
some sort of a climax of the
mathematical writers that are to happen
to be around the Bay Area and probably
that I don't know of any young east
coast that I would rather have anyway so
okay so Paul will be here a week from
Wednesday as I mentioned a week from
today Rosalie stemmer will be the will
be also lecturing she is a copy editor
at The Chronicle and she's been reading
your papers also now next piece of good
news is we do have your papers to return
to you today two sets of them and
Rosalie has another set which which will
probably get a week from today but very
clear and has gone through one set and
the TAS and I have gone through the
others and so you've got so today you'll
be getting three sets of feedback on
what you what you turned in and then one
more set coming next next week now I'm
in the bad news category
well the content of these papers was not
God was not a hundred percent pleasing
to your instructor I I nah let me I got
to say something about what is it that
that that makes a that you know makes a
professor's life worthwhile and
sometimes when when he what gives him
some pleasures and the answer is when he
can see that he has succeeded in
teaching something and it's it's usually
a joy to read term papers at the end of
a year and our exam to something and say
you know I bet this student couldn't
have done this if he hadn't if he hadn't
learned what I taught this quarter now I
didn't have as much of that joy as I
usually do when I read these drafts I
know I understand that their dress but I
had the feeling I most of them were
written before September or at least or
at least hadn't been looked at again
even since we started now so I didn't
have the feeling that you know I have
opinion we're putting on a great show
and appearing in all this and you can
sit back and relax and say oh yeah
that's groovy but when it actually comes
to doing it yourself have you actually
changed in one in one little bit
anything that you've ever done before
didn't see that much evidence evidence
so well that was disturbing to me and
for example 11 papers out of 13 had
which where there should have been that
now that's one of the things I've been
harping on for you know several times
but 11 out of 13 and in every case they
had at least two bad examples in the
thing now maybe there's two other people
you know who learned something here or
never you misused which and that
otherwise I told you that I I was an
offender myself at the time of my
scientific american experience 10 years
ago and Charles Dickens uses it wrong
all the time and that's fake list but
but in the 80s in America not yet so
much in England but in a mecca in the
80s it's people are getting very
ties to this and it's important to to
know the rule and so 11 out of 13 is is
is is a fantastically statistically
significant thing I mean if somebody
gets sixty percent of other votes in
elections consider a landslide and 11
out of 13 is way higher than that so
this means that but you that you people
don't don't know anything so I decided
that I have to resort to something
desperate and that is to give you a quiz
so for the next five minutes would
everywhere or at least raise your hand
when you're done so everybody take a
piece of paper out plead and write on it
two sentences one of which one of the
sentences uses the word that properly
where which would be a mistake and the
other sentence uses the word which
properly where that would be a mistake
just write these two sentences and raise
your hand when you when you when you
think about it if you can do it in one
sentence okay but that but that might
take you longer I get I don't want to so
just get just just get the sentences and
show that you understand the rule
ok
honor code requires that I leave the
room when you're taking exam actually
I'm not going I'm not I'm not I'm not
grading this so
I see you everybody still writing yeah
well you got some okay auditors don't
come doesn't matter if you learn
anything but CIA's okay i know the tea
did you okay now let's see is it
necessary oh it doesn't there ok ok this
is ok this is fine hmm so so far I got
11 royal write the story which I told
you is wrong the story that I told you
is correct which one of you is
responsible for this chaos correct ok
here we go it was not that he would not
speak but rather that he could not speak
oh that's two of ya I didn't define like
I wish you would um ok this the second
one is but the paragraph that is to
follow sketches an algorithm of the
simplex method in which box shall we
place our papers ok the day that has
white hair is my favorite the dog that
has white hair favorite colorless green
ideas sleep furiously ok the Declaration
of Independence which as we all know was
signed in 1776 is a fine piece of
expository writing but now yesterday for
the first time this quarter i changed I
had a write a paper where I had to
change that to which and it was miss you
six times and he was saying I know that
the name of the first program is X that
you know the first program is is it is
called X that does something and it
should have been whichever but ok so
this was this is a good example the
Declaration of Independence that as we
all know what
that would be wrong okay now the proof
that i provided in this chapter is based
on the fact that okay see the book which
lies beasts hide the desk so here we
have a bad one it should be see the book
that lies right beside the desk but see
the book which lies right beside us
would have a comma in it which would be
completely different meaning so that's a
that one's wrong I ate the cake that you
gave me I ate the cake which was the STA
lyst I had ever encountered that was
pretty good okay should I hurt him that
you should have should have been turkey
though okay here's some of which okay so
there's different ways to use that no
different ways to use which and the
problem the thing where were they
conflict is is when word I know which is
which I cheap shots yes okay so the the
case that is important is this it's like
in a sense i just use I don't say the
case which is important i would say the
case that is important i'm clarifying
which case it is and the and if you go
through the text editor and if you look
at the preceding symbol whatever
precedes the word almost always
ninety-nine percent of the time well
ninety-seven percent of the time it you
can tell if it's a wicked if it's a
wicked witch if if there is no comma
preceding it or no semicolon our right
parenthesis to some dash or some some
causing phrase then you then it should
probably be that instead of which if the
thing proceeding is is a preposition
it's another case where and then there's
these other exceptions that come up
three percent at a time I've been told
that I think it was Miracle Ear but i'm
not sure i've been told that
people use which in that correctly when
they talk but well it there is a there
is some saying that the rules are
different when you talk and then when
you then when in other words we would
say which in Auralee where where it
wouldn't be acceptable written and some
people say oh mary comes all right did I
get that right this one is fine and I
hope this is a sentence that uses
correct grammar okay I hope this is a
sentence which users click yes um
occurrences of which in natural speech
are close to 0 what happens the places
where which starts to appear are where
the speaker feels under pressure Oh like
giving a lecture suddenly people begin
begin to exhibit an unnatural sort of
diction which is one of the things that
is only if there's any doubt in your
mind about whether I feel comfortable
talking to an audience that's one of the
things that's especially disastrous
about the witch on paper that it not
only as a there's a loss of grammatical
information it also conveys a tone that
you definitely do not want you to cross
and I can't conceal my nervousness
face-to-face but on paper I can fool you
into thinking that I'm perfectly
comfortable yeah but but I think you
also agree that that the that the rule
was not at all enforced until about 10
years ago or 15 years ago very much
thought otherwise how can I calm for the
fact that all translations of the Bible
have wicked witches in an all over the
place
because classic assists Fowler 1926
right and and but nobody nobody actually
believed him until somebody trying to
figure out what he was what he was
saying about 1976 no good yeah yeah okay
well the the people who the people who
were writing professionally started
enforcing it very very much more in the
late 70s and early age then then God at
least I I I notice in novels that I read
that were written before and after this
time but especially as I saying
translations of the Bible that were
written after that time and so on now
those now the new English Bible for
example they have the best the best the
people in England to work on that were
supposed to be not only theological
scholars but they were also supposed to
be writers and they would it for style
so that it would sound good from the
pulpit and everything and there's
witches all over the place oh but
English editors regard this is nonsense
okay I thought Fowler was England Fowler
think is English but he was not himself
an editor and English editors regarded
this nonsense oh okay so it's a matter
of whether they do when the editors got
into power then it's the book it's a
pistol okay all right that's that's good
clarification here we are the paper
which contains many wicked witches is
otherwise not too bad okay I like that
one okay well I guess you people might
have learned so no no but mostly you
have this stuff online right so you can
just go through and and look for all
occurrences of which in your paper and
make sure that that the final draft time
you got to give me one perk for teaching
this course and then I thought thought
that something got for you okay okay the
terminal
okay see these are cheap once again in a
sense okay all the students that know
when to use which in that will pass the
quiz so you're not these separate self
referential sensors are something that
computer scientists think of right over
right right after that it's a good
psychological cool okay now the next
piece of good news I got a letter from
Leonard Gilman whoo-hoo i sent the
examples of your previous homework and
so he said your letter made my day and
then some and so on quite a class you
have I'm still reeling in belief that i
did not follow through my own precepts
anyone can reel in disbelief i can reel
in believed to also that I put in the
condition alpha unequal beta it wasn't
there for the first 16 or so dressed but
some gremlin made me inserted in the
final one here we have demons in in May
in that in Texas as well okay so he so
he encloses a new write-up of his own
which he was inspired by this although
I'm not sure he actually optimizes over
our student be solution but anyway he
was inspired to do this and so on he he
tried out are instead of tea for real
numbers and he says my primitive
facility still do not provide the
accident in sierpinski and then he says
he's talking about you know some
improvement in that in the ax in the
mathematics that was suggested but
instead of saying an increasing sequence
and unbounded sequence is better and he
says he is he's planning to put in a new
appendix in the next edition which will
extend he Stanford eyes so and he's an
emeritus professor as of three months
ago my goodness it makes me drool to
think of how much tiny must have to
revise that
now so that was more in the good news
category so you know that your your
efforts on homework are going to are
going to actually get into grant now
that the rest of today I wanted to talk
about let's see oh yeah one of the 11
rule that I've never brought up that
nobody's mentioned in class before that
I noticed as I was grading the papers
there's something that see if i could
try to to to formulate it there's and i
just found it violated about in about
three of the cases and if the rule I
never even thought never even I never
even was aware of before so but now
having seen that it you know you're done
wrong all of a sudden I realize there's
something to it and that is if you have
a title of a subsection in your paper
and then you start going into the
subsection and quite and these three
people in their first sentence they
referred back to the subsection as if it
as if it were an integral part of the
text they would use a prep renown that
would refer back to the subsection like
a subsection might be you know auto
bounded whatever boondoggles I don't
know and then and then that the first
sentence would say this is an
interesting idea you know sort of
referring to the subtitle as if it's
part of the text that are that the text
needs the subtitle in order to in order
to live now in fact you the unwritten
rule that I understand is that you
always write the sub tightly the text
and and in restated it anything that
might have appeared in the subtitle that
the text is there was text would still
make sense as a lecture being read to
lead to the person without that with its
up with a title removed but the title
was only there sort of stuck in the
margin or something as an annotation but
i think it's i think if you if you go
through and you actually when you see
the title there it sort of it sort of
goes into one part of my head that that
says oh yeah i know i'm now I'm seeing
something else structure this document
but but the other part of my head still
wants to be told that I'm moving into
that part of the structure is that is
that basically clear what I just said
you understand the point that when
you're eating so so you're given a list
of problems that are np-complete and you
would have a title saying the Traveling
Salesman problem another one would be
the Hamiltonian path problem another one
would be vertex cover problem so on
either all going to be examples but so
now you have a difference a different
title and so you get to a section called
the Traveling Salesman problem and and
now you would your first sentence should
not say and now you know and and this is
another derivation or this of NP
complete or something like this you
would say consider a traveling salesman
that must that must visit different
cities but you would your text would not
assume that the reader had read the
subtitle and integrated that I'm not
sure I'm saying it properly because it's
a rule I've never heard of before but
but I noticed that it was it was miss
miss used several times so that's a rule
for those now i want to to go through
some of the things that were interested
in in a paper that i was asked to read
byte by two of our grad students during
the summer i I didn't read it on time
they submitted it in August and I didn't
have a chance to give them their
feedback until september-october but
anyway as I was doing this I was
thinking oh this was I'm teaching a
course in writing I got lots of good
examples in this and I could and I can
show and I can show you in randy said he
wouldn't mind if i showed you this this
draft and so there he is grinning and
and in the comments that I that I made a
lot most of them have already been
covered I don't want to read you know
we've already had enough of review today
for things we've already done in this
class
but I did I did want to show you some
things about the technical writing that
arose here that I think are our general
interest and so this is a page this is a
paper presenting a rather difficult
result of about graph theory and in the
big end in the beginning section here on
preliminaries there's there's you know
definitions and this isn't especially
important in the paper on graph theory
because graph theory has has at least
four different sets of conventions at
different authors use some people call
it called Li say you have vertices and
edges others say you have points and
lines and every in this particular case
these I think both Ramsey and Alex had
learned graph theory from a textbook in
which the author you want to use the
word path it always meant a simple path
where other authors would would say a
path was any was any sequence of was in
any sequence going along the the
vertices along edges some people say
it's a simple path if you never visit
the same vertex twice and others would
say that that they would call it a walk
if it may be the vertex twice and they
would call it a path if it doesn't but
but those you know I never had a
textbook like that and and I needed it
almost anybody in the older generation
and this idea of distinguishing between
a walk and a path is like is far from
being a standard thing so when you write
a paper on on gravity or you have to
realize that you're getting readers who
from all different backgrounds not the
same as you and it's going to be the
same in in other in other fields that
are that are new terminology and
mathematics takes a while to crystallize
it and become and become accepted in
fact it's a very interesting thing I
think the equal sign you'd say it was
there ever a day when when equal sign
was not
was not well known among mathematicians
but in fact it took more than a hundred
years for the equal sign to catch on
Robert record wrote a wonderful book of
1560 where he is called though the
whetstone oval of wit and he said he
will use this symbol two parallel lines
in order to disable because nothing
could be more equal in these lines and
so on and he used it in his book and it
was a nice book but he was British in
people in England and France didn't use
that they had this sign they were using
it for there were a lot of competing
some people use this for minus some some
some descartes used it for what was it
anyway they were there was a lot of it
was it wasn't till more than a hundred
years later that that the the term for
equal sign finally was adopted by people
in more than one continent you know and
and and and there were all kinds of with
all kinds of opposition to it for a long
time people like I think wall is finally
won out and with his algebra book about
a hundred years after and but fermo
would never use this sign he would
always say in in in Latin equal aq and
things like that now so it took a long
time and people had headed who were
writing books on mathematical have to
say at the beginning what an equal sign
is in those days now we don't have to do
that anymore but you have to be aware of
the things that there are that are
diverse among your readership and catch
the and catch that let's see what do I
do here simplify oh okay I
well it's not a great it's not a great
point here but here he talks about a
path and he has and and he's he's given
a definition that took this is this is
one of the this these three lines are
one part of a of a four-part definition
definition 3.4 and has four parts to it
and this is by far the longest one and
the idea would be try to try to shorten
it if you can so that it's so that the
definition is more easy to remember and
doesn't look too formidable and in this
case he's got a notation that he can use
that he would just say w1 with the right
arrow and a plus sign over it which
means one or more occurrence one or more
steps and then he has a double arrow
with a asterisk over it which means
there are more steps so here here going
w 12 w 2 and then zero or more steps to
WK now you could simply say W one and
one or more steps to WK because w2 does
not appear anywhere in this in this
definition and so a simple rule there
but when you look the main idea is try
to simplify something it putting down
extra information doesn't isn't always
helpful sometimes saying more is saying
left communicating less now the
consistency is the next thing when
you're making it make when you're making
these definitions especially when you
have a paper with co-authors it's useful
to try to be consistent and so you go
through and you stay and you start out
and you and you've got definitions that
are sort of priming the pump for the
rest of the paper and so this has all
these nice definitions talks about a
Dominator and an immediate Dominator and
so on nothing wrong with that except
that on the following pages they don't
use the words anymore but they call them
parent and child now that would you know
no
that would seem obvious but I am in the
chapter that I am writing now on
probability theory I happen to notice
that very a whole bunch of definitions
at the beginning of the chapter that
looked fine but I realized by the time I
get to the end of the chapters I never
really needed them and they were there
was no point in in in getting him there
if I was never going to know if never
going to use him anywhere else in the
book it's something like the complaint
that firemen had about the way the way
people were were taught new mathematics
they would learn the definition of Union
intersection of sets in second grade and
then in ninth grade they would first
apply it to something okay now here's a
sentence of a couple of interrupts of
Molly interesting things here it says
we're doing a took some references to
the to the literature here and it says
gabon Targon show that for many
algorithms that had such a
multiplicative factor in their worst
case complexity the multiplicative term
can be removed and now I change this to
have the algorithms it's the algorithms
had such a multiplicative factor in
their worst case complexity but they
still have the the but the problem
there's a different tween an algorithm
for a problem in a class of all
algorithm in the class of all algorithms
for the problem the problem has a worst
case complexity but an algorithm is
something that that always that always
lived so so so for many problems whose
best algorithms had a multiplicative
factor then that was that was something
that's now different in the path from
the past to the present because gavel
and Sergeant found a way to get a better
algorithm but when you're when you're
talking about present and past tense the
quite the thing is that you know what an
algorithm is timeless okay now let's see
the question yeah I noticed that they're
using abbreviations on the bibliographic
entries there yeah you say some about
that yeah well first of all I would put
a space here I don't like that
I don't like that running running them
right next to each other put it I would
put a tie there probably and so that's
all the way through here you see that
should have a space but I didn't comment
on that now now this is a something that
actually each journal has its own
preferred bibliographic style and so
when you're when you're dealing with
preprints like this anything that and
anything they have a convenient however
thats enough thats raised a good point
because of their were on quite a few of
the term papers there were there were
cases where i would wear i suggested
that it was better style to try to write
when you we have a reference that your
sentence would still be a reasonable
sentence without without the reference
so that the reference would be really
parenthetical and not and not part of
the sentence and so and so here's the
girls look here's an example of breaking
the rule you see experimental data in in
in this paper here so getting this would
you know it would be better probably to
say experimental data gathered by lens
draw bracket lens 79 or whoever this Len
is I mean lynnster does an awful lot so
I was gambling on him Ling our okay
experimental day together by leg all
right then then bracket Lin 79 so
suggest such a thing now I on the other
hand if there's a it sometimes seems it
is some some people have this some
journals and books have the style that
they're going to put this they're going
to write out the author's name
completely in full here and a date and
in that case it seems pretty repetitious
to see those names all over the place
you know you say
you know you would take canoes and then
it would say bracket canoes 1983 does
something like this you know and so then
you then you do it you you try to make
it if they're if they're making the
bibliographic references on long drawn
out thing you try to write it in such a
way that it reads reasonably well I
remember my paper on go to statements
was was originally in the ACM surveys
computing surveys and and then it was
reprinted in another book where the
editor and the other book had this other
build a graphic style so the ACM style
was you just you just have a bracket in
a number but in the book had this thing
work was where you had to you know put a
full name in there in a year and and I
found that I had to make quite a few
editorial changes in my sentences when I
got the galley proofs because this
because the thing just didn't look right
anymore with this with the style so
there's no no way to so it does affect
your you're writing a little bit i think
though it's a good you to try to write
it in a way that that that you would
avoid something like this but that if
you take out the reference it would
still make a good sentence that's a
fairly good principle i thought is that
a comment on on why i think a lot of
times the generals recommend on style we
have author and there yeah I think the
Chicago Manual style says they give it
the primary reason for using that that
when you add something new to the
bibliography it doesn't change the whole
yeah if you use numbers oh yeah well
that reason disappear should oh no yeah
no yeah that's right no chicago manual
of style has a lot of interesting rules
that are that like about numbering of
footnotes and things like that that that
that were done in order to save money in
because of the of the actual way things
were printed at the at the time and so
they would they would recommend for
example not you know numbering footnotes
throughout a chapter instead of instead
of differently for each page and so on
because the particular composition
system they were using
found out a lot easier in tech certainly
finds a lot easier to now it's in but so
this is this is a way of giving a
reference that you don't have to change
it that you don't have to change it if
all the numbers change at the last at
the last minute um yeah okay right but
somehow this gives a clue but I but it's
almost too much of a clue i would rather
rewrite the sentences so that it so i
didn't know yeah you would in this case
if you add one more paper by the same
person in the same year to put in 1 and
2 after the after the name so you might
still have to change to make make
changes in the paper it's I'm sorry I
don't quite understand the point they
say after you write this paper you want
to put one more reference yeah it's also
a paper by the same what I don't know
well that's 79 a 79 d or something like
right this will go to make it so change
your paper oh yeah well we you still
have to make a change I see it it
doesn't it doesn't solve our problems
yeah okay i get i get the idea now
here's a right here it says some are
sown song algorithm to recognize and
they will be affordable grabs when given
a directed graph commagene comma with
distinguished vertex s comma i'm talking
about the comments here this was a long
long sentence and so they must have
realized by the time they got to this
point that you need a breath and so put
a comment here two of them right away
there you know but the real place where
the breath was up here are so on RB our
algorithm and so on to recognize grabs
comma that's that comments good then you
need one there then say when given a
directed graph to you with the signature
takes s comma can be summarized as well
so then now the structure the sentence
is is nicely set off by commas you've
got this thing in a position you but but
this come
no comma have to graph G with
distinguish vertex s no I don't see any
point in it that's in a position just as
well but there's but there's a sort of a
it can go fast enough you can say i
graphed you at the signature tag set so
they have to put a comma there too and
invite it by that time you've got so
much breath that you really you know
you're hyperventilating so okay now find
all self loops I I decided why not say
self look instead of loops again self
loops is an unambiguous term to you can
all the books on graph theory but a loop
some people you know so I so I just go
out of my way to be a little bit
unambiguous when I first use a term was
it was a suggestion simplifying
simplifying oh here was an interesting
cake interesting thing and it occurred
throughout this this paper where but
where is it okay first of all here he's
got the given a procedure here and it
says if any hjj greater than 0 has more
than so-and-so vertices edges then stop
now it turned out that if you look at
read this paper for content you'll find
out that h0 is already known to satisfy
the condition and so h0 doesn't have to
really be checked for having more than
certain number of edges but it does but
when you're giving the rule you can
still simplify the rule and forget this
restriction now you don't have to give
the most efficient procedure when you're
when you're giving the exposition you
just have to give the thing that's most
efficient for it for communication so
you did I would just say here if any HJ
has more than someone's over edges and
stuff now later on you can optimize and
say well by the way this you don't have
to check j equals 0 but there's no
reason to state the room more
complicated this point but now here's
the here's the interesting most
interesting thing about the paragraph it
says a G being the Affordable implies
that all the h JS r be affordable now
the h JS
here we're talking about all the h JS
this means the set of all h j for j
equals 12 whatever and it's a concept
that they need over and over again in
the rest of the paper so you could say
make to make the plural of a symbol the
most common rule is to put is to use
apostrophe s for for plurals of symbols
then then you get into trouble because
he's going to have HJ Prime's also in
the in the in the paper so you could say
just HJ you could say all the H sub J RV
affordable like that's that's done or
you could say each H sub J is be
affordable but probably if you're going
to use this if you're going to use this
with so many times in the paper what you
really need is another name for the
concept just think you know take out
your thesaurus and and say you know it's
going to be the auxiliary graph or
something like this and and because this
this is a this is not really a an
elegant thing to talk about all the H
sub J it's it it's it's so very it got
it introverted towards symbols so now
let's see ' here's where you want to '
for sure HJ HJ is descendants that's a
possessive that's genitive that we do we
want to have an apostrophe s in that
place but you see how often these other
places here of the h JS it would be
better to I think to have have some
power to have another name for the its
have another word for that but what you
have to think of something some way this
dismissed us this is John way to it the
way it reads now below vs. above
here's another case where space is
missing in between here and I would and
I would rather have a space between
their 4.3 below in 4.4 below it's like
he's making references in the middle of
a proof to things that are proved later
now this is something that Hardy does a
lot in his foot type on on in this book
on introduction to number theory del and
he has all the theorems numbered from
from one to five hundred and something
at the end but but they don't appear in
in the order of the of their proof they
disappear in the order of this statement
and and so at every point now he'll say
no and now we're ready to prove theorem
eight and here we are in the middle of
chapter 25 and that this is a little bit
disconcerting you wonder if somebody
isn't making a isn't you know making a
circular argument here because maybe
you've been proving something that basis
on that well still it's it's sometimes
helpful to ought to have a look ahead as
to what's going on another issue about a
blow versus above I'll have to get to
another day here's a place for a hyphen
in a in a compound adjective we can use
the one vertex path now on the next page
what do they talk about the two edge
subpath okay again good place for hyphen
okay now i told i talked about ties a
while back where we're putting a little
thing like if you're using tech which
they are to put it put putting a pizza
oven q would never the break would never
occur to be at the end of the line here
and there were quite a few of these
things where you'd say occurs in q prime
and then here it says occurs in p so
this idea of ties here's another another
case of ties sometimes the sometimes the
symbol wants to be tied to the letter
after it I wouldn't tie the if to the e
to I would tie the e2 to the is instead
of the other way around I would rather
have a break before they after
as I said it's not really is hard to do
that as you as you might think at first
it comes naturally now here it says
we're talking about vertex of distance
less than or equal D and it seemed to me
a vertex at distance less legal deal
with Sun a little natural or more
natural but here was there but that
wasn't the main point I want to make
here is it so see figure 7-4 a sketch
now somehow that that's that's an
example of what I call an unfortunate
coincidence in in in writing where
you've got well it's not it's not so
it's not so coincidental as some of the
other ones i said but there's a better
one is a better one in in section 10 in
on page ten here where it says all the
the V double prime vertices have been
deleted by this point okay now there is
a this idea of a coincidence where
there's a word that's used in two
different senses all of a sudden you're
finding that you know there's a point
there that's being do that you know so
you can't use certain idioms of English
in the wrong context where it's
misleading one of the term papers was
was the interesting study of airplanes
design and he's also mapping things
conformal mapping in the complex plane
so he's got planes and planes and it's
and they're both used in the same
sentence and you don't know which you
know the author knows what's plane is
talking about but this vent not not not
because you have to think of a way to
avoid these inary now these are cases
where it's not a where it's not a matter
of a type of graphic error but it's a
matter of really a coincidence no I
there's a find the book that I a book
that I have a that has a lot of these in
it at home it but apparently my kids
have lend it out to somebody else but
there's there there are some my favorite
one in the whole book was Nixon to stand
pat on tapes
what and there and there was one in
there where there's a picture of a lady
in upstate New York was leaning on this
on this supposed in front of her house
and he's talking about how she's been
elected chairman of the school board and
this is the third year in a row that
she's that she's held a similar post and
and some of them I must say I break up
so much I can't even tell you now this
happened also in in the in in in your
term papers in three or four cases is
surprising that it does but it does
occur and so you got to watch out but
you got to be aware of these
coincidences somebody you could you know
something if the word left as opposed to
write is also there's left which comes
from leaving and and in the one case I
so you say that something was left but
then if there's a right-left context you
have to be careful and so on so looking
for these these are ball coincidences is
a worthwhile thing to okay now I think
I'm cut about through my list so yeah
let's see no few more quick comments at
the end here he had on the illustrations
for this paper work particularly well
done they it's an example of an
algorithm and arm and it starts out with
with a sample graph that a person that
makes the problem understandable that
he's trying to solve and then he builds
on this by in case by following the same
topology and you can see the way the way
these vertices are lined up is
consistent between all of the things and
so as as the algorithm is doing these
things you can see you can see them
happening well there was one one problem
here it actually was was a mistaken but
the this is this is incorrect but they
but the main idea of all these figures
was was that it was very well done and I
suggested only that they add one more
one more vertex an edge from here to
here which would have made which would
have Illustrated a step in an algorithm
that they didn't have me that they
didn't have illustrated otherwise so so
I wanted to show you those because those
because a sequence of examples that
builds on the builds on each other is is
usually better than a sequence of
examples that are all random independent
of each other I think okay so thank you
you can come and get your papers now